a new pretend playground for local kids  is just hours away from opening up in  the southwest valley it's called kids  town offers an indoor city look at that  full of pretend shops restaurants a post  office flower shop a school for kids to  enjoy the owner tells us the idea was  born out of her own experience at the  local children's museum as a little girl  when she played in the make-believe  grocery store  wouldn't it be really cool if  it wasn't just a grocery store but it  was an entire town of pretend play where  the kids can really immerse themselves  feeling like they're big  and then moms can sit down and relax and  just watch them  play and have a good time  it officially opens tomorrow for health  and safety reasons she says there's a  reservation system right now you can  reserve a time slot on 8newsnow.com kids  will love that they will love it  especially once they're in the kitchen  they'll make fake meals and everything  they're going to dig it